So, to sum up, what is language and what is linguistics?
Language is a unique and organic communication system.
It is unique because it is only humans who possess it.
It is organic because it grows and changes all the time,...
...just like a plant or any organism.
Language can also be defined through its key design features.
It is unique because of its close relationship with the human mind, the brain, and society.
What about linguistics?
The role of linguistics is to analyze and explain language.
But we can go further than that.
Linguistics is also the study of the way language is used in everyday life,...
...the way it is employed.